now will you greet president William
Clinton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much bishop maya all the
members of the family and on a reason
bishop i thank you for many things but
especially for the decades of guidance
and genuine friendship you gave to
elijah it is true that almost things
actually 21 years ago he invited me to
new psalmist on the Sunday before the
election and I remember you know you I
love that you introduce the staff
because we'd all be dead without the
people are helping us but if you're a
present your staff is always trying to
tell you why you shouldn't do something
where you shouldn't go somewhere I
remember this very well as soon it's
Tuesday Sunday before the election why
would you go
I get why you want to go to an
african-american church but why would
you go to Baltimore I mean come on there
are so good to you they always vote for
you what would you go for Elijah
Cummings he's been in the house 15
minutes he literally hadn't finished one
term yet I said I just got a feeling
this is something we ought to do and if
we do it we'll know whether it was right
or not and so the bishop rolls out the
red carpet thousands of people were
there and you may remember we got in
some trouble didn't we we got in some
trouble they people critici--
thus for having get-out-the-vote event
in a church instead it was inappropriate
and as I remember
Elijah reminded people that our
constitutional rights including the
freedom of religion the freedom of
assembly the freedom of speech dependent
on people giving voice to them and
elections end of debate then I got to
listen to Elijah talk that they you talk
about a lousy deal it was I had to
follow both the bishop and the lies are
coming and at least I'm getting in ahead
of you and President Obama today I'm
just sooo
[Applause]
in my old age on the warm up fact I'm
glad to do it anyway Elijah was great
and he ended would his quiet and
reasoned and rhythmic voice growing into
his booming voice by quoting that
wonderful verse from the 40th chapter of
Isaiah they wait upon the Lord will have
their strength renewed they will round
up through with wings as Eagles they
will run and gotta go weary they will
walk and faint not
and he just kept doing more and more the
crowd was going crazy over the course of
these last few days I've had a chance to
think a lot about Elijah's life he
really did sort of mirror Isaiah who had
one of the greatest one-liners in the
history of human affairs when the Lord
asked whom shall I send and who will go
for me Isaiah said here are my Lord send
me Elijah coming spent a whole life
saying send me an entire lifetime it's
not even a teenager when he hauled down
to the swimming pool and joins a group
to integrate it and for his trouble gets
banged on the head with a glass Marvel
living on a lifetime scar which he bore
with on earth and then the people of
Baltimore sent him to Annapolis and then
his Senator Washington on behalf of the
rest of the nation I'd like to thank you
you did a good thing
and then I was looking over all the
things that he worked on just in the
four years we were together he was
elected the year I was re-elected in
1996 he had this amazing array of
interest but we all know now that at
least until certain things happen his
legacy is how ardently he honored his
oath to protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States
[Applause]
I think he did it for a lot of reasons
he loved the fact that his parent humble
wives made his a great American story
and he loved that it confirmed his faith
but he knew that without the
Constitution the laws that were passed
under it the rights that were guaranteed
by it and the abuses it was designed to
prevent without that Constitution he
would not have been in Congress and so
he said to himself I am certain everyday
I will not let this promised be sullied
and he did his best and while doing his
best and fighting his heart out sticking
up for Hillary and lots of other people
many of whom were voiceless and weak and
will never be known while doing all that
he actually made in one of the most
partisan periods in our country's
history a lot of Republican friends why
did he do that how did he do that I
think he did it because everybody could
see he was a real deal he was doing what
he believed his heart was in it and I
think he did it because no matter how
hard he fought and how passionately he
argued he tried to treat everybody the
way he wanted to be treated the way he
thought America should be treated
[Applause]
you know you can't run a free society if
you have to hate everybody you disagree
with I mean
sooner or later if if you've been
married 45 years and both of you were
thinking you're gonna have a
disagreement or two sooner or later if
you're in a business or a team or in a
campaign and you're thinking you're
gonna have disagreements
he believed that he's to treat people
and what you wanted to be treated and he
believed if everybody accepted his broad
endearing inclusive definition of one
America where we respect our differences
and think what we have in common matters
more and we all live under the same set
of rules and we all believe that under
those rules those of us who have more
than we need should do more to help
those who don't have enough everything
would work out okay now that's what he
believed and being friends he was so
proud that he could help resolve the
personal spat between his Republican
congressional friend and new member of
the Democratic caucus but he believed so
here's what I want to leave you with
Elijah spent his working life in the
tradition of Isaiah he went again and
again and again but I think in his
lasting legacy to us
we should think again about the prophet
Elijah for this reason he was about to
be killed for his ardent promotion of
his faith he hid in a cave either within
or next to Mount Sinai he received a
message from God to go up and stand on
top of the mountain and wait for the
voice of God to speak to him so look
he's already found a hurt pretty hard
time just like at the end of Elijah's
life he's already had a pretty hard time
you got to go through this too so
there's a lot of standing on the
mountain and the huge wind came so
strong it roped the rocks of the
mountain but the Lord was not in the
wind then an earthquake came shaking
everything but the Lord was not any
earthquake then the fire but the Lord
was not in the fire and then what does
the scripture say a still small voice
[Applause]
Alijah by that point had gotten rid of
all the pomp all the circumstance all
the glory for the still small voice I
love this land I love every minute ever
spent with him every conversation we
ever had I loved his booming voice but
we should hear him now in the quiet
times at night and in the morning when
we need courage when we get discouraged
and we don't know if we can believe
anymore we should hear him but our
Elijah be for us what he himself heard
the still small voice that keeps us
going keeps us grateful keeps us happy
and keeps us moving thank you question
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]